[Music]
I'm pierced by something men do you
think men women look it seems to be like
women look at their bodies more and are
more objective I don't think men look at
their own bodies like that do you agree
you know I disagree I disagree you don't
think you think men some men some men
who are we talking about anyone we know
we're talking about him I think a man we
all know by the name of Dax Shepard has
a massive appreciation for the male form
and says it wholeheartedly because he is
so comfortable in his sexuality like
watching the Olympics at our house with
him and his friends it's always on pause
always on someone's body part because
everyone's in a man's body part can I be
honest the majority of them are men so
every now and again he'll be talking
about a female frame but mostly it's
weird muscle groups on the male body a
lot of growing muscles if you know what
I'm saying the man in your life
well-known Dax Shepard very funny guy
great man you saying that he will pause
a lot when he's watching the Olympics
yeah on a male athlete and focus on
their growing muscles yeah sometimes
they're alive Allah answer the question
yeah
well first of all if you're telling me
you have watched the Summer Olympics and
it hasn't occurred to you everyone's
wearing spandex you're lying
come on the Olympics were like a penis
festival it's hard enough but like I am
a little bit more like oh I didn't even
notice and he's like pause look at this
slow motion screen in stream yeah he's
looking at different body parts the boys
has appreciation for the frame I mean
he'll focus on a shoulder on a bicep on
a tricep he just he's very comfortable
and he appreciates a male forum just as
much as I do that's great that he's
comfortable that way I think so too
yeah yeah I am NOT